okay hello everyone for people joining
this live stream we are doing a little
bit of welcome language design review
looking at
question
generators so it's been a while since i
looked at this like months so i'm
a little bit out of out of uh
i have to remember what was going on you
want the you know 10 000 foot view
before no oh really i mean i i know that
but but um
all right
i've never heard of question pool
yep this is a brand new thing we're
proposing
as opposed to a question bank
yeah it could be called bank could be
called bank
or question collection
or question okay i think pool and bank
are used in more widely
uh
i mean
this is essentially a function this is a
a list of questions from which you are
picking
that's right all right
in the comment use case from which a
server is picking for you
and so
but i mean aren't there often
constraints among the questions like you
pick one from this set and you pick
another from that set and so on
yes
yes this is a building block for a quiz
this isn't a quiz itself
no i understand but but at each step i i
don't understand because you know
there's like a random sample function
because you don't want to ask the same
question twice for example
right random choices random sample
right yeah i mean the second use case
where there's that n
where it's serving multiple it's using
random sample internally
um
but is the point of this that you can
say cloud deploy this and then you get
some kind of question generator thing on
the back end
essentially yes um
and we could kind of make that work but
really it should the deployment will
happen when you push the button in the
question notebook
but essentially yes
all right i don't quite see the
importance of this particular thing i
would have thought it was more
well go ahead i mean this is a thing
that you are it's a meta level beyond
the individual questions
exactly right so you know if you want to
write a quiz for your class and you want
different students to get sort of
different
examples
different instances of a question
and you want them all predefined and
kind of static
then this is it it's simple
what about parametrized questions that's
question generator
so that the next the next thing why
isn't question generator just
we had we had wedged these two into the
same symbol and made it one thing
and it got ugly and complicated
and so we decided to make it to symbols
we could revert that if you feel
strongly okay all right let's take a
look at this all right so
i'm i'm i'm
what are we actually going to review
here because i mean these this obviously
doesn't run here or or can you it should
it should in today's maybe
maybe just uh
i mean just evaluate like question
object semicolon to make sure that the
packet's loaded maybe it's not this is
from march 31st oh well that's why why
why is it from march 31st
can somebody go chase that with roger
yeah yep i'm asking
i think roger may be out today um
let's try this other build here
build zero nine two eight
i'm just taking forever to launch for
some unknown reason
and is refusing to sign in which is a
bad sign
also it says 13-0
is that
i don't know what that that's from
i mean this should be that version that
i i think just the welcome page image
hasn't been redone
yeah i believe that's true
still certain march what the heck
what the heck
i mean we've certainly had successful
builds in the last two weeks
haven't we yes we have
oh for goodness sake
okay
for corey if she's here since we're
heading into a season of design reviews
it's really important to make sure these
things are up to date
of course it wasn't there maybe maybe
you can make sure she has that message
yeah yeah we got that yep
um okay what are we going to do here so
am i going to look at somebody else's
screen or what um
can we look at the examples on lower
down on these pages
even if we can't run them i feel like
they give you a pretty good idea okay
great what we're trying to do
all right question generator
so what we have before is question
object
which has the question to ask followed
by the assessment mechanism is that
correct
that's right
that's right
so here
this is
kind of like an api function
yes
this is very weird it is a little weird
but it is kind of like an api function
yeah
very weird
very pink
yeah it's probably because it's march
31st
if you want me to share and run examples
i can't but no but i mean what let me
just understand so the first argument of
question generator
by the way i mean we have a function
document generator which was one of our
less successful in my opinion
right you guys are aware of document
generator i am
i bet schroeder is i bet sylvia isn't
true
okay
so it is a
trigger the document generator
okay parameterize document generator
now that the task system is
more coherent
these things
should get more attention again i think
well when they first came out the test
system was
a little bit less reliable and
harder to understand than it is now
are these examples still right
i think they've been updated even you
know it's task execute instead of
yeah
yeah okay
all right so let's go look at this
question generator again
okay
um
let's see
so
why is there a function at all that does
this why isn't gen funk
just a pure function that gets applied
to whatever arguments it should have
uh well we want a symbolic
representation of this thing so we can
deploy them
and
distribute them
okay but but i understand but so what
the thing
is an instancing of gen funk
right gen funk is a template
that has certain parameters
right
why should gen funk is a pure function
gen funk is a pure function
why on earth isn't
i mean this
thing
is equivalent to
i mean this thing here
right you almost don't need the question
object wrapper but you need something
containing the guts
that would be the question object rapper
no i understand but so this
is you know
right
that's all it's doing
yeah but it's not doing it until the
time comes
right it's like a held form of that
the question generator does not evaluate
oh no okay okay
i'm thinking when does it evaluate it
evaluates at the time
when
the goal is to make that very
customizable there's a futurized table
that's kind of the start of the idea
um
for that
so you you know there's all types of
things if it's like an adaptive quiz you
need to wait until the previous
questions or one previous question was
answered before you generate
this is the kind of thing that i
fumbled during our duolingo discussion
and the kind of thing would be useful
for duolingo type
type idea
okay
well
uh okay so hold on
what what is the thing that
puts the action into all of this
the question notebook see this will only
happen
when it's used in a question notebook
which is really the end goal
is that you have
this special environment question
notebook
is a notebook where
normally it's like a giant form it's
it's like a a question notebook is an
instance of a form notebook is that true
yeah it's a it's a flavor a form
notebook
okay
well typically you edit a bunch of
things then you press submit
you well if you're the author you press
generate if you're the student you press
submit yeah
yeah
okay but all of these things are
things where in the question notebook
there is not a literal question there is
instead a question schema or a question
generator in place of a literal question
somewhere right
right
so in other words if i make a
new
programmatic notebook what do i make a
question notebook
in yeah should be right
that should be right there in march
yeah
well maybe you can do create you can do
create notebook a clash notebook even
back in march
okay
um you should check water complete is
now working
i think that was part of the same
thing that we did
okay
black is the color of q a
has that been looked at
yeah this definitely went through design
okay fine
okay all right so
then
i say here insert
a question
yeah
and if you want to insert a question
pool that's another
thing that is will be available under
insert
yeah that's schroeder has that ready to
demo at some point if you want to see it
we don't have generator working yet but
we have the pools working
yeah i can share my screen okay all
right but but then
okay so that's a raw question now the
alternative is that that question
you want to be parameterized exactly
okay
and
but it's parameterized one question at a
time
or it's parameterized in the whole bank
right so
uh
you can cert we definitely want to
support multi-part
questions
and what we have said right now is the
output from this question generator
doesn't have to just be a question
object it can be
a list of questions but how does that
work in here i mean because it would
share a parameter space oh in the in the
authoring notebook yeah yeah it's going
to be sprayed apart because it could be
question seven question one question
i think it'd be helpful to see
schroeder's demo of question pool
because i think that's gonna show us go
ahead and let's should we see that now
yeah our ideas basically have a
like a sub notebook pop-up
go for it
okay so can you see the screen yep
okay so
when you insert a question pool it looks
like this
and here's a question pool that i
already added a couple questions to so
you click it and then it opens up
a sub
like bob said a sub notebook
that is sort of pared down and then in
this notebook you can add whatever
questions you want in the pool
and in the generator case i think there
would be another section at the top of
this notebook where you generate where
you specify parameter space
yeah hold on hold on so then you press
finish press finish
and then it updates this
which is not intended to be directly
editable right
yes correct
you're going to insert can you go under
insert
and then can you insert
the
do the pull down there
that's it
yeah yeah no i get it okay question pool
so hit question pool there
okay
okay so that's a null question pool okay
so hit edit question pool
they called the pool within a pool
we've talked about it sylvia and i have
talked about that at length um
we i don't think there's a reason why
there can't be but i don't think we're
gonna document it on the first go
okay
okay
all right
so then we add these
and
and
a question pool
so if i want
10 questions
all
i don't understand this i want 10
questions
all from the same random question pool
but i want them as a sample so they
never repeat how do i get that
right so
i think in here we should all we also
need a uh and yeah field so that's like
an argument of question pool yeah where
it will do the random sample and then
it's all the same yes but then how do
you spread those apart and
you know how do i put numbers how do i
put 15 minutes remaining on your exam at
this point or whatever it is
so what i'm saying
rifling content in between in that
scenario but i mean you could put if you
you can put arbitrary content in the
original authoring notebook
yeah above or below
but yeah i i i understand but i mean for
example let's even say you're numbering
questions here
what mechanism do you have for numbering
questions
well yeah that's what i mean is like
right now
it will just give a bunch of
a bunch of questions they won't be
numbered or anything
uh
we could i mean numbering wouldn't be
hard to yeah to make automate we could
and we could have some sort of option in
the question pool where you just put in
like
you know uh show whatever you want to
call it
intermediate operations
um
you know that
puts content in the student's notebook
in between each one
it's getting pretty complicated that
that is that does sound kind of
complicated
but i i mean i don't i think that's a
complicated scenario where you have a
question pool where you want to serve
multiple pieces and you want
different stuff in between each one
yes but i think the idea of numbering
questions is going to be really common
oh yeah yeah we can that can just be
an option in the in the um settings menu
on the authoring notebook automatically
number questions
okay okay so
uh all right so the question here is
in the symbolic form of this
i mean the whole notebook doesn't really
have a symbolic form
right i mean in other words
i'm kind of reluctant to have
okay where would you use the symbolic
form of question pool or question
generator
right so in the courseware repository
how exactly in other words you would
have a is it going to be a shingle
yeah yeah i mean that that's the idea is
that we could it could support you know
any granular content from a single
question to a
question pool to uh
you know a full quiz to a full
course
okay so hold on hold on hold on so
question object is at the question level
question pool is lists of question
objects what's at the next level up
what's the complete quiz
yeah it's it it's a notebook
it's a notebook expression it's just not
this yeah
right but is it obvious that that you
need to have functions here that go
beyond
i think for deployment i think for
yeah i think
i think it'll be very
useful
to have this symbolic representation and
not just have it be things that only
live in notebooks
okay
all right so
let's go look back could you bring back
up the um
question pool
and
do you have the ref pages
oh i i don't so i'll give back the share
okay
all right
question generator
okay what the heck really is this so
this is
so let's see what's the description of
question object
represents
a question
represents the question q
um
okay
what resolves okay we've got a question
object how do you resolve to get a
particular question
right and programmatically you just
open close afterwards that's what we
have in right now
okay
and i think for question pools it's the
only way it would only thing it would
only do zero arguments probably for
question generator
we have this
idea
where it can take
data that gets passed into the
generation function which would allow
but humans probably wouldn't use it but
the question notebook would use it to
allow adaptive quizzes
so you could pass in all your assessment
objects
and
so on
or some summary thereof
exactly
right
but i don't understand i mean if with
question pool
unless it's in one
clump
you don't get to do the no repeats thing
unless you have some very elaborate code
that goes and i mean yeah
you could pass back up question ids to
exclude
or i mean and when you deploy these
things
all the tracking is already happening
so you know we already know which
students have been served assuming
students are authenticated we already
know which students have been served
what questions
and
you know we can make sure they don't get
repeats within the same
session
even if you're calling the same pool
more than once
okay look
i'm sorry i'm a little tired here hold
on a second let me just try and
wake up and think about this
okay
i don't get this really
what the heck is the generator now
because
the generator
so really what we want
is you know in a sense question table
and question map
you could
think of it that way
i mean in other words this question
pools like question table
and
are the q sub i here functions
or just question objects just question
objects
without parameters without parameters
okay whereas a question generator uses
question object functions with
parameters
right
yes
and what it's doing in the end
i'm so confused i mean really all it's
doing is it's mapping
because in the end you've got to fill in
those values from somewhere
and i don't quite understand why you
don't just take gen funk
and fill in the values directly i mean
what does this thing eat well i mean
that's why it's delayed rules because
typically
the values are going to be some
parameter space like the examples we
have typically are like random entity or
random real you know um
yeah but i know some why that isn't just
in the generator function why don't you
just put random real you know random
whatever into the generator function
well i mean typically a lot of times you
want to use the same parameter
repeatedly right so it's cleaner to just
define it once
it's like you know
it's like api function kind of
or
like i said it's different um
yeah i mean we could you
it could work like with it could be
could have a holding attribute um
well i i hate those but i'm yeah kinda
understand
this thing
how does it relate to document generator
does it does it eat and produce things
in the same way or is this a question
generator function question generation
function or something
because it's different
let me refresh my memory on
document generator
real quick
okay
actually you could you guys yes it it
it's it's similar to
housing
pretty similar
except it
um
except it's deployed in a notebook it's
not deployed
in a cloud object
but the template here
no it's not similar the template is a
string is simply oh i see it's a
function that's applied
no because it has does it have a
template apply
um
does have an implicit template apply not
in the programmatic form but our my
thought was in the um
i think it has an implicit template to
fly
it must yeah
oh what a mess
because you for whatever reason don't
want to have a template apply
we could do it that way if you
no i don't i think people will have
trouble writing their questions as
template objects
yeah
yeah
well i'm not sure about that i mean this
is a mess
that's horrible looking
yep
um
right
the the
saving grace is that hopefully people
are going to be writing these
creating these in the
question notebook
they're not you're not getting off the
hook that way
look this thing is either
it isn't really a generator it's not a
freaking generator it's it's a it's only
a generator if the first argument is
random
otherwise it's just a width
right
well i mean it doesn't evaluate it it
returns an object that
will generate on demand when you want it
that's it
usually unless it has random in it it's
going to generate the same thing every
time
well i think that's the idea of like
how you could get these
quizzes that are adaptive so it wouldn't
have to be from random it could be from
a previous answer or something
how does the previous answer come in
again
so the
you know the hash is a combination of
the of the
what kind of first argument what kind of
whatever is pest
just association joint of association
okay so if i give up um if i repeat one
of the parameters that's been fed in
at the end
i'm toast if you did well
you'd be overwriting it right if you did
prime test of association n goes to five
it's going to use five every time
right it's gonna it's because you know
association precedence
um
what other function do we have that
merges together
uh
associations like this
i mean there's lots of things to merge
associations but there's
not like a high level thing like this
that i know of
um
can you okay
talk among yourselves for just five
minutes i will be right back okay
okay
all right let me see if i can
and you can uh
um
yeah
you can keep everybody i don't know
whether people are
paying attention on the live stream but
maybe you guys can
can discuss this a bit i'll be right
back
okay
i mean sylvia what were the other
you know
uh concepts of this that we've had
i mean the first iteration was the width
one
but this one is so much
less scary-looking it was just basically
a
inert wrapper around a width basically
yeah
does api function not do the
the joining
no
everything in the hash of api function
is just coming
from
although maybe we'll accept things that
aren't
explicitly in the schema
as well
but it's not really joining anything
okay yeah i understand now it's like you
can overwrite
a value like if it's y goes to four and
you pass it right there
yeah yeah i mean it is
very similar to document generator
which we hadn't really
looked at as a
you know
design point for this
i hadn't used it so long
yeah the arguments are in the opposite
direction obviously
i don't think i've really used it i mean
i think i'm aware of it but i've never
used it myself
i used it in the early days
of resource system for internal stuff
and
did not fall in love with it and
abandoned it
um
but
i mean that's definitely an alternative
to just make it
work like with
yeah i mean
there's really no way of getting around
writing some sort of template question
object function
you know
yeah
it's just how you apply that
the other thing we could do is we could
get rid of the question object
in there
and have it
be three arguments
certainly it takes in like a question
question interface and then the
assessment function
or something and then it's just like
attention and then it's just like doing
like a template apply
but
i mean even steven agreed that it's not
people aren't gonna like writing
questions that way
people are gonna i would i would rather
write questions this way because like
you take a question uh you know a lot of
times you might take a question object
that already exists as a
static thing and you go in and you add
slots
um it seems the most logical to me i
mean it doesn't look pretty when you
write it out but i think
if you're someone
you know doing it
hmm
um
right and
to steve inspire me about
you could just put it right in there
we should have examples where we just
put it right in there here and there
aren't any parameters
right
all right i'm back maybe slightly higher
what did you guys figure out
we still like our design
we you know the we don't like the idea
of
just making it a width
um
okay let's go through we think we need
this we think we need this templated
form of question object where the
parameter space is clearly defined
and we think this is
this this is the best conception of it
that we came up with
okay
so
the problem is
the generator okay so there are some
parameters that come from the first
argument
now there are other parameters that are
coming from elsewhere is that true or is
that not true
uh
it's true especially in the world it's a
question notebook that's just crazy it's
just crazy we don't have anything else
that works that way what happens when
there's a collision
well i mean we we have look you've got
two associations you're feeding in
okay one that's a built-in association i
don't understand
why
so your idea is you want parameterized
questions
yeah i mean if you want question object
functions
and i don't understand why you're not
doing it like this why why it isn't the
case you've got a bank of question
object functions right so you say
there's an ordinary question object and
there's other ones which are
parametrized questions which are
separated in your
uh in your you know in your in the in
the courseware repository okay
and once they're separated okay then
what you do
is
you're saying things like
okay so then you've got the collection
of these functions right just like
you've got a question a collection of
questions right that's one set of things
you have is it's a collection of
questions another set of things you have
is a collection of functions
right
right
okay so those functions when you use
them in a notebook the first thing you
do is you resolve some of those things
right you say this
goes to this now what do you get when
you resolve that
do you understand my question
the answer is you get a message you get
a question object i don't know but look
look look look look watch this
you don't you don't you get a mess
okay so you do that well when you've
messed up the parameters i don't
understand no no no no no no no
you've got two sets of parameters here
okay you've got one set you're feeding
in as part of the question
generator
thing okay you've got other parameters
which are not distinguished in the
question object
that are coming in
from the use of the question generator
correct
right which have like
two very standardized names
what are they uh i think we put it in
the question generator docs we called it
like assessment data and you know no
something like that no
so you're muddling up you've got look
you've got one thing which is coming in
for an association
what do you mean it has standardized
names then why
because this is going to be done by the
question notebook
but then why do we have a separate
function
look what you've got is you've got a
function which is which is oh you know
which is stacking on two kinds of
association applications
right
right
okay we've never done that before it's
rather undefined
it's not clear what happens when there
are name collisions it's kind of a mess
i don't think it's the right design
so let's think about what we do
okay
in
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to have something where you have
a parametrized question
which has its parameters coming from two
places
is that correct
yes
okay what are the two places and what
parameters does it get from those places
right one is this whatever we want to
call it driver generate the first
argument of question generator
and the other
is the standard metadata associated with
the quiz
we mean standard metadata
what has a standard metadata question
object doesn't have a standard metadata
does it
no quizzes no but question notebooks
have standard metadata that they will
pass into question
wait wait but they're not passing them
wait
generators
into question objects they're only
passing them into question generators
that's right
that are mixed up in some random way
with the parameters that the question
generator has the question generator
already has resolved at the time of
compilation time effectively from the
question from the quiz notebook
correct
sorry i did can you say that one more
time so there's a okay
there's two moments in time there's the
quiz notebook turning into a sorry
there's the
whatever you call it the quiz source
notebook turning into an actual quiz
notebook right that's one
moment
when some of these parameters are
resolved no no there's none of these
none of the parameters are resolved at
that time
okay
and then you have this weird list of
times when the parameters will be
resolved
yes so we have this you know what we're
calling generation time option where you
can
everything is resolved
when the at once for every question
generator everything is resolved at the
same time
they're not com it's not like the
parameters from the generator and the
parameters from the quiz are coming at
different times they're all coming at
the same time
yes
i don't like this design i mean i'm i'm
not immediately figuring that out
we could we could make it hash too
and then we wouldn't have to do it we
wouldn't have anything
what
hash to
the
information from the quiz
by the way question pool
again i don't understand i don't
understand how this is supposed to work
if you pick up a question pool
the
it is not an operative form that has the
number of questions that you feed to it
it is in the question pool itself is a
number of questions thing so it isn't
the case
that
question pool is itself an operator
do you get what i'm saying
unlike the question generator which is
itself an operator
that gets
light it isn't operators just doesn't
take arguments right
oh god
yeah but if you want 17 questions you
put that in the question pool not in the
thing you're feeding to the question
pool which means your idea that you have
a collection of question pools just gets
blown up
right you can't just take yes because
you can't just take a symbolic question
pool and apply it to something
you said i'm saying
i see what you're saying yeah yeah i
mean we could make we could make the
number of things queriable from the
outside as well right you could
wait a second because i mean if you're
going to have in the on the shelf
so to speak question objects
question pools
and question generators that's what
you're basically putting it that's what
you basically have in mind so i remind
you
okay
so i don't understand
given that the question generator has
these parameters
which are
just mostly random things why don't you
put the randomness
into the question object itself
why did you put the quest make the
question object
is it because the question object is it
because of an evaluation issue
do you understand what i'm saying
you can't put in a question object can i
put random into a question object
without trouble
sure
no but what does it do does the question
object evaluate its arguments or not yes
yeah it's not holding at all okay so
then that's not going to work is it so
you're hacking it by putting it inside
this generator you're hacking the fact
that and the fact that in the way that
api function is a hack and form function
is a hack and anything where you specify
a function as an argument as a hack
and all functional programming is a hack
no it's a hack no no it's not no no it's
not in that sense it's not in that sense
api function actually takes those
parameters
the function
the function we're specifying takes the
parameters
and this it's just like document
generator like you pointed out earlier
no it isn't because document generator
has a template apply in it
look the thing that i think
i don't understand
why you don't have a supply of question
objects
and question object functions
okay how is question object function
different than question generator
it isn't a new it isn't a new symbol
it's just
a function
it is a question object which is
it is a question object wrapped in a
function
well
we want a unique wrapper so we can
deploy it and have it have custom
deployment properties
and we can distribute it and it'll be
a symbolic object then i would call it
question object function
and i would call it question object
function
and have it be something where you feed
it
the parameters of the question object as
one argument
and then you feed it again so in other
words the way it would look is
it would say question object function
of the thing with all kinds of you know
hash whatever's there ours
okay
if you really don't i don't understand
what the xxx is here is that a question
object or it's there's god's of course
object it's the guts of a question
objective
there's two arguments right
and they both have hashes in them
i guess so
okay and then you apply that to an
association and there's no there's no
amphison in there they're just empty
naked hashes
well it's a function function i would
assume
okay so it's holding
no oh god this is a mess
this is a mess how do you know what the
parameters
are
okay you don't because it doesn't need
to know because you're what you're doing
is you're mixing two sets of parameters
and that is going to that is going to
bite you
i can't tell you exactly how but it's
going to bite you
what about what about my proposal to use
hash two instead of
mixing associations
how do you use hashtag
so you have all your you know
hash one is the association that
is give given by the
horrible interesting and hash two which
you don't need to use at all if it's not
an adaptive test or something like that
is is the internally specified standard
quiz metadata but but if you do that
you've got to take apart hash one all
the time
no you don't
no you don't do it do f open bracket
hash a
comma hash two and apply it to
an association and then
arbitrary
additional arguments
it works
does it
really
is this actually documented to work
i i couldn't tell you if it's documented
but it works well we better check
because i don't think this is a i don't
think this is a thing
it's interesting that that works
i mean actually no that's right it's
because it's hash sub a
that's right hash a is equivalent to
hash sub a
right and numbers are special right
right that's why we like
key and slot and stuff like that to
distinguish
i mean this is i admit that that works
that's not totally ridiculous i mean
that at least solves the problem of
mixing
parameters
yes
um
let's see
i hate the name question generator
possibly because of runoff from document
generator
okay
i mean question
function
seems fine
sylvia
steven schroeder do you guys have uh
name ideas or avery
i use the word question generator so so
many times that it has lost all meaning
to me
anything starting with the word question
begins to
i don't get
i just don't understand this i don't
understand why we want this look why are
you putting this here
why is this not i mean that's the thing
that you put
i don't understand why don't you just
have that thing in right in there
well
you're going to use n repeatedly
circulating so use width
so use weight that was the first design
we came up with we had with raptor and
everything and it was
uh much uglier than this to remember but
i don't understand why you want this i
mean why don't you put
look i mean we could have an idiom where
it's question generator of with and then
no no no no
no no no no no no the issue is look
you've got this function
i don't understand why is this not
you know you're using the same parameter
in a lot of places we that's the thing
you do very often in the system this is
a pure function it's not going to
evaluate you can just say with you know
n equals random random integer
yeah
that's yeah we could do that i think
it'll be uglier than this but
i think we should do that i don't think
we want a new mechanism
it's much more difficult for people to
learn a new mechanism than it is to use
an existing mechanism
because if we use we use with
okay that fills in all the parameters
other than
i don't understand look the only thing
you're getting is
you've got some hack to do with
deployment
that's yes
it's not a hack
don't be pejorative
it's code
no but the issue is
you've got
i don't know
i i don't think this is right
but you know look
look
i mean right now we don't have people
using what we built so far do we
um internally we do
for what
um danny finn's been using it for some
of the um
consulting projects and okay but wait
wait have we used it for from you for
example
uh we're going we're starting to
it isn't in a live
course yet
i think mcloone's used it for some cbm
stuff
look okay
okay
after an hour
i may be about to reverse myself and say
look
i don't see an obviously better way to
do this i do not like the way you're
doing it but i don't see an obviously
better way to do it
that's definitively better
okay
so there's a certain argument we should
introduce this is experimental
and have people start using it and find
out you know you said you find with very
ugly but you say that because you've
actually tried to use it
yes i think that
you know the whole document generator
mechanism
every time i try to use it i'm like
completely confused
and it takes me
you know a whole bunch of time and it
usually doesn't even do what i want is i
mean we could do both i'd like
can you look at the
there's no reason that one argument form
couldn't be the same as the tournament
form with an empty list
and then if you just put within there
it'll work
right
i'm not sure that's really helpful
i mean
people don't understand i mean we want
to write questions that we can and it'll
we can make the one argument form be the
same just resolve to
yes but i mean the whole mechanism that
you have here the reason this is not
going to work
okay is that the whole mechanism you
have it's the same thing with document
generators it's just a completely
different new mechanism from everything
else in the system where else in the
system do we have something where
default values are fed in like that you
know even an api function that's not how
it works
api function it's an input function
that's given in that first first
parameter this is a completely different
mechanism never seen before
and you know the only time you're using
it is for random generation right that's
the only thing you want to do you're
trying to use it this way because you
have things where you have the same
random object that's going to occur
multiple times actually usually twice
usually it occurs exactly twice once in
the question once in the assessment
function
yep
right and i just think it's completely
crazy to have a completely new mechanism
that has never been seen before
elsewhere in the system and where
everybody who sees it has to learn that
mechanism
a fresh new mechanism it just doesn't
seem right
you know the the cognitive cost to learn
a new mechanism exceeds the lack of
elegance of having an existing mechanism
yeah i see i understand your point
i mean
which means that what we would have
is
in the question bank
or in the question object bank or
whatever
there would be things which are
parameterized questions
okay which say with n equals random
whatever no i still think we need a
dedicated rapper
that but i'm saying we can get rid of
the first argument if you think that's
too
uh you know
discordant with the rest of the system
but i think we need a dedicated rapper
that's not just because of these
deployment things because of these
deployment i think it need it can't have
function head
the
thing it can't have function head it
won't work
head function that's the function
yeah yeah
um
let's get rid of the first argument for
now
i think we i think that's fine we can do
that and it's safe to if if
if i
if if our idea
somehow it becomes obviously right it's
safe to move in that direction again
even sure from then on
it's yeah it's a safe but except that
it's going to be hash one
is the argument that you give to that
pure function for the assessment data
whatever it is
i didn't even think about the
assessment data
yeah
it is
how is the assessment data set up in a
question object
it's an assessment result object which
can be
uh
which you know can nest assessment
result objects can nest and they're
queryable
so you can you can extract
you know
the uh the correctness from every
question answered so far
the score from the
third question you know you can query
like a data set
i really don't like this i i really
don't think it's right i mean i think
it's going to bite us
in some way
you know i think people are not going to
understand i think every single time i
mean look it's one of these things where
maybe it can work where people are just
sort of
you know
just remember it like they remember some
random
you know idiom
i look i don't see an obvious way to
solve this
um
maybe we just have to go for this
version having this the way you've
designed it as experimental
although it would be
do you want to change the name of either
generator or pool
what's the difference between pool and
bank
i don't think there is one
if i'm wrong about that somebody correct
me please
question choice question um
but also this question about whether the
thing has a single
i mean look okay i would like to make a
math point this design is kind of hard
right so i'm not giving you guys a hard
time
for i mean i don't think it's right but
i think that untangling it
is a
you know i cannot see an untangling
and
you know
so
i have the advantage of having tried to
untangle things like this for many
decades so i don't think you know you
didn't i don't think you guys missed
anything obvious
i just don't my
gut feeling is this is not right and
it's tangled up in some way that we will
maybe only learn after we start using it
but but you understand what i'm saying
the question pool right now because it
is not based on having an argument
you get what i'm saying
yes
um
is uh
is not usable for multi-pool
things if you get what i'm saying
you can't pick it up you have to go
grunge inside it
right
i think people are usually going to want
that
yeah i think i think what it is is like
a random variant
i mean it is yeah
i mean really that's like it's almost
like a random
question random choice or something
i mean really what it's like is a random
variate where you give it a blah blah
blah you know gaussian distribution as
its first argument
although that again just takes the
number n there but you want something
where you can pick it up
from the
overall
course repository
and just stick an argument into it
do you get what i'm saying
yes
account by an argument yeah
yeah account yeah yeah
yep
yeah i think that makes sense it does
make sense
for
the count to come
actually okay so maybe
ultimately i mean maybe we should call
it random question function
the generator well we have a question
not the generator not the generator the
um
function in there makes me think
i feel like as a teacher like pool or
bank are going to be words that they're
more familiar with
yeah but unless they understand that the
fact that it's random the fact that it
generates look the pool
is what's in it
right but it isn't
look okay
guys
unfortunately we ran out of time
let's try to look at this one more time
but why don't you plan on just using
what you have and making it experimental
okay and we have a few changes that
we've decided on that we'll make
but we'll we'll keep i mean i
i think there's a way to unscramble this
i think you've got to think it through
carefully i think document generator is
not a success
okay so we don't want to you know pile a
lot of stuff on top of
that um
but
okay
sorry i i am
uh
yeah um
right
um
yeah okay i thought this was going to be
the easiest meeting of my day
yeah
it would just be questionable
the questionable one isn't that
complicated we can we can certainly
nail that i think
um right this system generator is tricky
that's are you
yeah have you talked to anybody else
about this for people
i mean that
yeah we have a
a lot of people happy to
give us their ideas and meetings and
we've taken their ideas
all right okay well this party needs a
bit more heavy lifting but i think i
think the right thing to do is to start
actually deploying with this and see
what happens
okay
and i think you know
and it could be that it's just fine and
it could be that it will get tangled up
in some corner case
and require you know much more work
but if you want to you know bring the
bit back one more time if we have a
chance
um and particularly if you think about
this a little bit more
i mean you you you heard my i i think
and i think once the question
notebook-based workflow is in and you
can see that all come together yes that
will be the whole conversation as well
right so we'll try to get that working
and then we'll bring it back to you
sounds good all right thanks a lot guys